[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec à la une le
conflit en ukraine vue par les enfants
dans les vosges deux petites filles
ukrainiennes et russes sont amis depuis
leur arrivée en france il ya cinq ans
une jeune amitié qui résiste à la guerre
est une bien belle histoire à découvrir
dès le début de cette édition avec
vosges télévision il est l'un des
symboles forts du conflit le drapeau
ukrainien affiché un peu partout en
soutien à l'ukraine il est fabriqué
notamment en 48 heures par une
entreprise bretonne vous allez voir un
reportage de tvr dans ce journal
ce n'est pas à l'école buissonnière mais
presque une classe maternelle de la
sarthe organise chaque semaine une
sortie en forêt avec cliff découvrir la
nature et son environnement tout en
s'amusant classe en fera un sujet
devient lmtv dans un instant et puis la
fête autour du fromage fondu à découvrir
en fin de journal le premier championnat
de france de fond du s'est tenue il y a
quelques jours en haute garonne romandie
et bonne humeur étaient au rendez vous
comme nous le montrera la rédaction de
via occitanie milana et angelina sont
des amis inséparables
l'une est russe l'autre ukrainienne
leurs familles sont arrivés en france en
2010 est réfugié est hébergé dans un
foyer des vosges les deux amis
participent aux collectes du moment pour
soutenir les populations dans une
paroisse dirigé par un prêtre polonais
qui se mobilisent pendant ce conflit un
reportage tout en émotion de marie
danielle robot vite et de l'aiea
turquier de la rédaction de vosges
télévision
dans un conflit fratricide qui voit la
russie envahir l'ukraine il y a parfois
des histoires qui font du bien lorsqu'on
les regarde à hauteur d'enfant et ce
jour là deux petites filles inséparables
qui se ressemblent comme les soeurs
milana 9 en russe et en galina disant
ukrainiennes sont venus avec leur
famille et leurs amis de géorgie pour
participer à cette opération solidaire
qu'est ce que tu as amené là
dicaments des pansements pourquoi pour
le trend pour les aider parce que ya la
guerre balle craignent à ma famille et à
mon tonton il ya mes grands parents sur
la télé on regarde la guerre et à des
guerres et à plein de maisons qui sont
détruites les famille de milana et
angelina se soutiennent depuis leur
arrivée en france en 2010 est réfugié
elles vivent dans un foyer à rupture
moselle elle partage aussi les mêmes
origines arméniennes elles ont le
sourire leur amitié se fiche bien d'une
guerre menée par des adultes mais depuis
quelques jours la jeune milana subissant
comprendre les attaques d'autres enfants
de son âge à l'école un fait a dit des
trucs un très violent sur un poutine et
moi j'aime pas en fait je crois qu'ils
disent exprès la non-violence donc qui
fait qu'elle est perturbé à que
pleurer entre l'école on ne ne plus
dormir la nuit enfin cesser ses tricks
en piqué le père piotr tenait à leur
montrer cette statue de notre-dame érigé
après la seconde guerre mondiale et qui
surplombe la vallée un lieu idéal pour
un message de paix à deux voix que
milana a tenu à dire en russe traduit
par angelina
d'âge ne bride cheville mais c'est une
nouvelle vague la guerre fait trop de
mal nous voulons vivre en paix et tout
signe
voilà des images qui remonte le moral
tout comme la solidarité d'ailleurs qui
se déploie un peu partout en france
depuis plus de trois semaines c'est le
cas notamment en haute garonne vous le
voyez sur ces images de la dépêche du
midi ou le conseil départemental a
débloqué une enveloppe de cent mille
euros pour acheminer des produits de
première nécessité à la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la pologne au total ce sont
déjà deux camions qui sont partis
et dans l'aube aussi le département a
déboursé un peu plus de cent mille euros
pour soutenir financièrement
associations et ong qui aide les
réfugiés sur place une aide financière
en complément d'un accueil il y à
quelques jours d'une cinquantaine de
déplacés femmes et enfants venus de
l'ouest de l'ukraine sont arrivés en
pleine nuit image fournie par le journal
la halle st clair notre partenaire
et dans cet élan de solidarité les
petites communes ne sont pas en reste
avec leurs moyens elle tente notamment
de réunir un maximum de matériel et de
dons à romilly sur seine près de 3 les
habitants sont mobilisés tout comme le
maire qui se prépare à affronter des
bouleversements sur la durée à que le
réfugié en hausse du coût de l'énergie
notamment un reportage vous allez le
voir de canal 32 sur place
après avoir été mobilisés pour le centre
de vaccination les agents municipaux de
romilly-sur-seine participent à la
collecte de dons pour les ukrainiennes
la pharmacie
des masques des couvertures des
dentifrices du gel douche un petit peu
tous que ce soit pour les ukrainiens
pour un autre pays je pense que tout le
monde doit être solidaire la protection
civile se charge ensuite du tri de
l'acheminement des dons ici ce lieu de
collecte est ouvert du lundi au jeudi de
8h à midi de 13h30 à 18h quant au maire
il n'anticipe l'accueil des réfugiés une
mission qui nécessite le contrôle et la
validation des services de la préfecture
nous allons déjà en tête un ou deux
sites de transit potentiel que nous
mettrons à disposition de l'état quand
celui-ci ne dira nous avons besoin d'un
centre de transit nous accueillerons
prioritairement toute personne venant du
man degré de la soeur notre ville
jumelle dans le cadre du comité de
jumelage l'accueil des familles elle
travers puisque déjà il faut collecter
ceux qui sont prêts à accueillir et
riffier que les conditions d'accueil
sont possibles ensuite voir sur quelle
durée il pas vais l'accueillir pour agir
dans la durée en raison des risques
d'augmentation des tarifs et des
disponibilités de l'énergie le maire
souhaite donner l'exemple le mardi 22
mars à 18 heures il prévoit de couper le
chauffage d'une partie des
établissements publics ils demandent
également l'accélération de
l'instruction de certains dossiers en un
mot là où on veut implanter une centrale
photovoltaïque qui fait l'unanimité sur
l'aérodrome a promis sur celle là où
d'autres veulent implanter des éoliennes
et que ça fait l'unanimité dans leur
secteur de façon à ce qu'on puisse
édifier l'ensemble de ses sites
d'énergie renouvelable si possible au
cours de l'été pour qu au cours de
l'hiver prochain nous soyons le moins
dépendants possible sans attendre le
maire invite chacun à abaisser son
chauffage de 1 à 2 degrés
plus de trois semaines après le début du
conflit l'invasion de l'ukraine par la
russie était le thème principal de
l'émission face aux territoires sur tv5
monde avec gérard longuet l'ancien
ministre de la défense écoutez à ce
propos ce que nous a dit le sénateur de
la meuse sur ce conflit 800 millions de
dollars des deux militaires
supplémentaires à l'ukraine annoncé joe
by dernière est ce que cela peut faire
la différence notamment vous êtes ancien
ministre de la défense dans les airs qui
est la problématique du président
zelensky aujourd'hui alors non ça ne
fera pas la différence
800 millions c'est une somme importante
cela permet en particulier aux
ukrainiens de se fournir en drones et
les drones de combat de nouvelle
génération peuvent assurer une forme de
protection et compliquer la vie des
appareils russes au dessus des villes
assiégées mai
l'armement c'est hélas une évidence ça
coûte très cher et surtout il faut le
mettre en oeuvre avec des gens formés
avec une logistique qui assure
l'approvisionnement
parce que si vous avez le système mais
qu'il vous manque tel ou tel équipement
il devient inutile et donc les 800
millions de dollars c'est un geste
significatif et dans ce climat de crise
c'est d'ailleurs une performance que
l'armée ukrainienne qui n'est pas
considérable
puisse tenir encore comme elle tient et
refaire mon cette page dédiée à
l'ukraine avec l'un des symboles du
conflit le drapeau ukrainien
manifestants et collectivités la fiche
un peu partout pour montrer leur soutien
durant cette guerre devant les mairies
devant les écoles ou encore au balcon et
ses près de rennes une entreprise qui
est capable de réaliser ses drapeaux en
l'espace de 48 heures elle croule
d'ailleurs sous les demandes venues de
toute la france explications de capucine
colin gül au chien pour la chaîne tv air
en bretagne
aujourd'hui donc nous avons pas mal de
demandes donc toujours des mairies
illégalement des particuliers a très
bien chaque jour emilie rabbin
comptabilise une quarantaine de devis
pour des drapeaux ukrainien alors il ya
deux types de demandes via les pavillons
pour afficher au mas déroulement des
drapeaux pour les manifestations de
soutien en 48 heures la société est en
mesure de les réaliser de a à z les
demandes viennent donc de la france
entière on a tout le matériel hi-fi on a
bien sûr les machines machines qui sont
prêtes on a faim on a un pub de stocks
de tissus et puis surtout on a fait des
trucs purs qui vous permet de définir
des drapeaux aux les envoyer rapidement
l'atelier a directement su répondre à la
demande un coup d'oeil à la bible des
drapeaux et l'impression peut être lancé
le jaune c'est le 115 c
est le bleu c'est le 313 ses tunes en
fait une dénomination internationale qui
permet à tout le monde d'avoir les mêmes
références de couleurs dont la pièce d'à
côté les couturières finalisent les
drapeaux en fonction des demandes chaque
jour ida louise en assemblée de
vingtaine et puis c'est 150 x 225 donc
c'est
le deuxième plus grand et on a mis si on
a disposé plusieurs cartons et
différentes tailles on les classe par
taille comme ça on sait pour qui
exactement
en dix jours 250 drapeaux ont été
réalisés dont celui ci qui flotte
désormais sur le fronton de la mairie de
rennes et restons en bretagne dans cette
édition pour mesurer maintenant l'impact
de cette guerre sur notre économie les
français le savent les prix de l'essence
ont fortement augmenté ces dernières
semaines un coup dur pour le
porte-monnaie des consommateurs mais
aussi des professionnels à lorient ce
sont les pêcheurs qui voient leur
activité pénalisée leur chiffre
d'affaires est liée au prix de l'essence
face à la flambée certains ne peuvent
plus aller en mer d'autres peinent à
rentabiliser leur sortie écoutez ces
témoignages recueillis par caroline
chevrollier pour les chaînes tv aux
était déçu de l'échec du couple
télégramme place on a aussi cette
particularité la hausse est de faire
entrer le gasoil dans les frais avant de
faire le partage bien sûr plus le gasoil
et cheikh ba plus partagée fait on
surveille un petit peu qu'elles sont
les réactions des pêcheurs et les
intentions des pêcheurs suite à ces
hausses la priorité c'est quand même
qu'en local on soit capable de
s'approvisionner le plus proche possible
je conçois port de lorient et aux cris
et bretonne sa vague idée sur ce qu'il
faut que nous proposons à nos clients
savoir qu'on va encore trouver dans les
fins de semaines à venir
voilà des inquiétudes quant aux prix de
l'énergie qui risque de durer malgré la
remise de 15 centimes par litre
d'essence prévue à partir du 1er avril
dans le vaucluse vous allez le voir une
petite commune tient peut-être une
partie de la solution
l'autonomie énergétique piolenc 5000
habitants abrite la plus grande centrale
solaire flottante d'europe 23 hectares
de panneaux solaires installés sur l'eau
qui lui permettent de produire
aujourd'hui plus d'énergie qu'elle n'en
consomme un projet rendu possible grâce
à un partenariat avec des entreprises
locales maxime perron du journal la
provence a rencontré le maire de la
ville
la capitale de capteurs flottant de
l'énergie renouvelable même pas à mimer
élus majorité disent le maire ils
ont lu et relu quoi ouais donc j'ai tenu
mes menus 2018 pour avoir dans les
capteurs installés cela que c'était
plutôt une contrainte puisque nouveau
les gays régulièrement 55 mètres de
clôture parce que tout était clôturée
donc aujourd'hui je n'ai plus la
rentabilité est par contre j'ai
dividendes qu'ils retournent tous les
ans
voilà une initiative qui pourrait
inspirer d'autres territoires et les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle en
pleine campagne une partie d'entre eux
était interrogé il ya quelques jours par
les élus locaux représentants des
communes départements et régions ils se
sont vus notamment exposé la vision des
candidats quant aux relations envisagé
entre collectivités locales et état des
échanges qui ont duré plus de trois
heures et qui sont à retrouver sur le
site internet de lcp
dans le reste de l'actualité de nos
territoires la fin du port du masque
obligatoire à l'intérieur à l'école dans
les supermarchés ou encore au travail
vous pouvez de nouveau respirer
librement et revoir les visages vous de
vos collègues une bonne nouvelle prise
avec précaution néanmoins par certains
écouter ces quelques réactions
recueillies par jérôme aubron pour la
chaîne de la voix du nord ou et aux
télévisions
je trouve ça beaucoup plus simple et
beaucoup plus vivant on voit des têtes
tout ça ça fait plaisir moi ça me change
pas grand chose je vais continuer à
mettre le move qui puisque on sait
jamais mais si on n'a que ça arrange pas
tomber j'en ai sûrement je mettrais
quand je vais aller au magasin laon
villebon encore pour l'instant ça peut
aller quoi enfin ça dépend le nombre de
personnes grands contrats
prudence donc et sachez que le port du
masque est obligatoire dans les
transports collectifs et les
établissements de santé il est aussi
fortement conseillée pour les personnes
vulnérables ou positive au qu'ovide 19 à
quoi ressemblera les vins de nos
vignobles en 2050 la question a de quoi
intriguer à cause du réchauffement
climatique
et c'est pour se préparer aux
bouleversements dans nos vignes que des
chercheurs tentent d'anticiper ses
conséquences dans le vignoble girondin
les recherches théoriques viennent de
passer dans une phase concrète un
vigneron du médoc bernard magrez test
les effets du réchauffement climatique
sur les vins ou du moins sur la
production du raisin l'enjeu est simple
comprendre ce qu'il faut faire pour
continuer à faire du vin dans 30 ans une
plongée dans la cuve du futur avec tv7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
c'est une parcelle de ligne de 2
hectares comprenant pas moins de 84
cépages différents les traditionnels et
les oubliés du vignoble bordelais ainsi
que des cépages dits méridionaux issus
du pourtour méditerranéen où même le
géorgie elle a été planté en 2013 par le
propriétaire de ce cru cassé mais
d'aucuns bernard magrez
depuis quelques semaines elle est
équipée de câbles électriques un peu
particulier ils sont traditionnellement
utilisée pour réchauffer le carburant
des réservoirs d'avion en chauffant et
bon simuler l'action du réchauffement
climatique sur les vignes selon julien
le court directeur des recherches des
vignobles magret et donc la d'ignorants
la paix sont qui fera un deux trois
degrés de plus que la température
ambiante et dès lors à accélérer sa
croissance et accélérer son
développement c'est exactement ce qui
est attendu dans les scénarii changement
climatique en 2050 selon les experts la
température moyenne pourrait augmenter
de 2 à 4 degrés l'idée est donc de
comprendre comment les différents
cépages plantés ici vont réagir à ce
réchauffement de quelques degrés quels
seront les propriétés des raisins
produits la démarche ne s'arrête pas là
il s'agit d'identifier les cépages qui
seront aptes à produire des grands vins
dans une trentaine d'années dans les
murs de cette propriété viticole
médocaine son propriétaire installé un
cuvier expérimental pour produire des
mini fication à grande échelle le but de
ces recherches est donc de savoir quel
sera le goût des vins de bordeaux à
l'horizon 2050 est question les cépages
qui donneront les meilleurs résultats
pour continuer à faire des grands vins
typique du vignoble girondin dans une
trentaine d'années d'apprendre à
vinifier ces nouveaux cépages ou même
les cépages existants d'apprendre à
vinifier autrement pour continuer à
produire des grands vins malgré
lâchement climatique qui sait travailler
les températures fermentation trail
peut-être avec des mesures différentes
le champ des possibles est complètement
ouvert outre l'effet du réchauffement
climatique et la sélection des cépages
qui pourront mieux résisté l'autre but
est de comprendre l'adaptation des modes
de culture et de vinification à ses
raisins à l'avenir pour continuer de
produire des vins gironde le premier
essai de ce programme de recherche est
prévu pour la future récolte 2022 les
bouteilles qui seront produites seront
conservés pour voir l'aptitude au
vieillissement de ses vins expérimentaux
sans transition dans ce grand jt des
territoires partons dans la sarthe à la
découverte d'une école pas comme les
autres une école buissonnière
une fois par semaine les élèves d'une
école maternelle passe quelques heures
en pleine nature ils touchent ils
ressentent et ils découvrent tout ce que
la forêt peut leur proposer hélène
galiana a enfilé ses bottes et les
accompagner à la chasse aux dinosaures
rien que ça un sujet de lmtv sartre sur
place
dans la classe de la ligue oiseaux le
vendredi c'est le jour de la
une fois par semaine les élèves de cette
classe de maternelle passe la matinée
dans le petit bois qui est à quelques
centaines de mètres de l'école
si tout prend son sens quand on doit
transporter un gros morceau de bois si
on est seul on n'y arrive pas donc là
effectivement on a besoin de se faire
aider par un ami un copain ou une copine
et les rôles sont un petit peu aussi
partager les téméraires sont pas
forcément toujours les mêmes et on cède
aussi quand on grimpe on prend des
risques et on s'assure avec les autres
et avec les autres on fait aussi
travailler son imagination et qu'est ce
que tu cherches pourquoi tu fais en
troupes qu'en faire parce qu'on va
trouver le livre ouais il ya des oeufs
de dinosaures ici
comme on a des classes multi-âges les
plus grands bas favorise aussi le fait
que les petits puissent aussi suivre un
peu le mouvement en fait ils font rien
de plus que ce qu'il ferait
habituellement c'est à dire jouer
grimper sauter s'amuser et cb
une initiative qui dure depuis bientôt
deux ans en tout 52 élèves de 2 à 6 ans
profite de la forêt peu importe la
saison
de bien belles images et une belle
initiative pour le développement des
plus petits ceux là sont beaucoup plus
grands et déjà en âge de conduire si les
200 étudiants de l'université catholique
de lyon sont installés depuis plusieurs
mois déjà dans leurs tout nouveaux
locaux à annecy
l'inauguration officielle de leur campus
alpes europe n'a eu lieu qu il y a
quelques jours seulement vous le voyez
sur ces images de la rédaction locale de
8 mont blanc la nouvelle structure vient
compléter depuis la rentrée l'offre de
formation locale écoutez à ce propos le
recteur de l'université interrogé par
emmanuel jo nous nous sommes une
université catholique y en a cinq en
france donc c'est pas énorme et donc ses
universités se voit confier une partie
du territoire français donc le nôtre va
de dijon à marseille et donc il y avait
quand même un petit manque de dire nous
sommes à lyon rien qu'à lyon mais nous
ne sommes pas ailleurs donc on s'est
interrogé sur la pertinence au fond
d'eux une présence plus proche du
territoire et donc effectivement et une
conjonction de facteurs qui font que
c'est annecy en premier qui a été honoré
le facteur évidemment d'une convention
avec l'université publique passée nous
sommes là non pas en concurrence mais en
complémentarité avec l'université
publique la tente du monde
entrepreneurial local et puis le
évidemment le les élus locaux et si la
musique était utile pour mieux apprendre
à diriger des équipes après quelques
mois de pause forcée le limoge business
club était de retour avec une nouvelle
conférence musique et management devant
près de 200 entrepreneurs des thèmes
liés à la gestion comme l'innovation la
transformation numérique des entreprises
ont été abordées tout en musique vous
allez le voir un reportage de 7 à
limoges par charlie des fonds et alain
dru
management et musique l'attelage semble
improbable et c'est pourtant le thème de
ce nouveau limoges business club co
organisé par les dcf et le festival
mille et une notes si l'analogie chef
d'entreprise chef d'orchestre semble
évidente c'est pourtant une facilité de
l'esprit c'est souvent la comparaison
elle a ses limites parce que le chef
d'orchestre il à quelqu'un qui est au
dessus de lui c'est le compositeur et
donc lui il est le serviteur de la
composition génial qu'a écrite selon le
cas mozart schumann ravel debussy et il
doit rendre au mieux cette partition et
cette partition est les écrits de note à
note alors qu'un chef d'entreprise il
doit réagir face à des circonstances qui
sont imprévus pour autant la méthode est
valable et dans sa société
l'entrepreneur porte cette double
casquette la partition est à écrire tous
les matins 80% du temps est consacré aux
ressources humaines pour qu'abandonner
on puisse avoir un morceau qui sent bon
le chiffre d'affaires et qui une année
gregor au sein du personnel et que mais
tout le monde s'entende pour manager
fixé la ligne la partition mais il devra
également prendre en compte
l'inventivité des collaborateurs leur
capacité à improviser sa déception
l'histoire des multiplicateurs c'est à
dire que si vous avez dit possibilité
pour la première mesure ça veut dire
qu'avec la deuxième joueuse en abaissant
qu'à la troisième leçon à dix mille cas
la 4e 10 mille etc à la 5e' mesure du
menuet vous êtes déjà cent mille
possibilités l'improvisation quand elle
se passe ça peut être formidable mais
elle se base sur des bases des socles
des compétences et une équipe pour que
cette progression soit harmonieuse
management et musique sont deux éléments
qui se marient très bien reste désormais
à combiner souplesse et rigueur pour
bien manager
prenons maintenant la direction de monte
carlo dans cette édition où le très
célèbre café de paris est en pleine
rénovation
la brasserie s'est installé dans un
autre lieu la salle empire de l'hôtel de
paris le temps des travaux le nouveau
bâtiment du café de paris s'étendra sur
deux étages et a notamment pour objectif
de mieux s'insérer dans le paysage
princier explications au micro de la
rédaction de monaco un show on fait deux
choses en fait on harmonise un peu
l'ensemble de la façade parce que quand
vous le regardez de la place ça passe
encore mais quand vous le regardez du
wan monte-carlo de l'hôtel de paris il
n'y a pas un mot qui va avec l'autre ça
a été fait par raccroc par ajout et
c'est pas homogénéiser donc un ont le
mot génise et 2 on comble les espaces
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas utilisés
c'est à dire en gros temps de regarder
le café de paris la partie droite et on
remonte la d'un étage et demi pour
revenir au niveau de la partie gauche du
bâtiment actuellement et puis une toute
autre ambiance pour terminer ce grand
gîte et des territoires la région
occitanie accueilli il ya quelques jours
le premier championnat de france de fond
du la fête du fromage s'est déroulée
dans une ambiance festive et a vu
s'affronter 21 équipes entre amateurs et
professionnels
la fondue un plat typique de la montagne
mais pas seulement comme vous allez vous
en rendre compte dans ce reportage
d'hervé lisa pour la rédaction de via
occitanie
c'est la fête à montréjeau la fête du
fromage la commune accueille ce dimanche
le premier championnat de france de la
fondue amateurs et professionnels au
total 21 équipes participent à la
compétition quatre sont d'occitanie
parmi elles vincent vergne sa femme anne
et à son de nîmes et représente la
provence et des nouvelles voies du 100%
italienne et donc mes fromages de brebis
du larzac et du causse noir avec de
l'ail et les aromates les arbres de
provence classique
mais omar un cerf-volant et marjolaine à
chacun sa spécialité pour faire la
meilleure fondue sont aussi récompensés
l'animation et l'originalité les fondus
sont françaises mais aussi suisses
belges hollandaises ou même brésilienne
pourquoi c'est pour faire voir tout
simplement à tous ceux de mon village
qu'il n'y a pas que la fondue comtoise
elle est très bonne et y'a pas que la
fin du xi c'est l'excellente il ya les
fondus à montagnat les fondus en bord de
plage et et que de la femme nue on peut
en manger à n'importe quelle température
et à n'importe quel niveau d'altitude et
c'est surtout aussi pour amener un peu
d'animation l'homme à mon village et et
l'animation est bel et bien là pour
l'occasion près de 800 personnes sont
venues assister à la compétition et
déguster une bonne fondue
s'accélère allez me viennent aussi goûté
au fromage et des autres régions et du
coup ça permet de goûter quelque chose
que on n'a peut-être pas l'habitude de
manger régulièrement chez nous donc du
coup c'est bien ça a fait plaisir et
puis sur une ambiance coptes à fait
génial les trois équipes en tête qui
gagne un accès direct pour le
championnat du monde de la fondue qui se
déroulera en suisse en octobre prochain
pour la messages reçus pour tous les
amoureux de la fondue et donc rendez
vous en suisse dans quelques mois pour
le championnat du monde cette fois ci de
la fondue c'est la fin de ce grand jt
des territoires merci de nous avoir
suivis rendez vous dans une toute
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]